find out that that boy is actually a
young program oh what a Jabba the Hutt
survived that explosion the Mandalorian
will spoil that Palpatine survived and
also how he survives
[Music]
welcome back I'm Melina this is rogue
theory and today we're talking about how
the first episode of the Mandalorian is
going to spoil the entire Star Wars
universe but joining us today are all
fun characters we got Erik Bosse all
right suffering from a chest burster and
then we have linked himself 80s leg
Joshua open Shire come joven was so
special about you it's so great and then
marina Mastro's is some sort of flower
monster she won't tell us what it is
yeah a little stop lowers maybe a
comfortable costume right before we
started you've been complaining about
her neck coat supporting the weight
immediately so see how long she can last
I have faith that you won't pass out
guys this week it was revealed that the
first episode of the Disney Plus series
the Mandalorian is gonna have a quote
dramatic Star Wars universe spoiler what
a little vague and I like that yeah boy
yeah we know it's traumatic Star Wars
universe and spoiler no other details
but a lot of people are like oh man
maybe it'll reveal the you know ray is a
clone or something which be so stupid of
them to put in their TV show that comes
out a month before one subscribers
marina knows I said it you're a flower
monster yeah it's got a lot of triangles
and like in Native American markings so
if it's not gonna be we're not we're
interested it's not gonna be about the
rise of Skywalker then what are we about
to learn about the Star Wars universe in
the first episode of the Mandalorian I
want to hear your rogue theory
this is the entire podcast yeah should
we start with Eric frein to try to start
I have a bomb borrowed time here so the
mandalorian will spoil that Palpatine
survived and also how he survived I
cannot turn my head you can make your
own gasping sounds I heard you do it
when you put that on Palpatine has
projected himself he got pooped in the
air shaft or whatever that thing is
called right he fell down and he
vaporized and when he vaporized he
projected his essence or his like mind
or whatever you want to call it into the
wreckage of the Death Star and he's
hiding there and then in the beginning
of the Mandalorian they're gonna be in
the wreckage of the Death Star and then
like a band of whatever the Bounty
Hunter is gonna be in there and then
it's gonna be like you know in 2001
Space Odyssey when he's like hello Dave
yeah I'm sorry Dave I can't do that it's
gonna be Palpatine's voice and then
they're just gonna drop that he's there
but can we hear your Palpatine voice
hello Dave and also how he survived so
he's just chilling on the wreckage of
the Death Star what do you mean wreckage
like he's just in the walls like in
Amityville Horror oh he's in the
computer yeah and so he's in there and
he's chillin and then also in the new
trailer for Star Wars they show the
wreckage of something and I think that
wreckage is how they're gonna he's gonna
get back into a body of some kind gotcha
so for anyone they could understand I'm
not sure if the microphone was
everything any of that up your idea is
that sexy Palpatine has been sexually
hiding
in embodying body some sort of phallic
leftovers of the Death Star and he is
kind of like waiting to remove his
essence elsewhere and this is an old
Seth tactic that herbal and not not many
but we do have yeah I do like it's an
old Sith trick the lamp always got to
destroy every object around a corpse
yeah exactly and so we're going to hear
a voice and that's gonna be the big
spoiler a little bit is gonna be sexy
palpitating based on your theory will
then Palpatine are they just gonna fire
like how that was a weird spooky voice
we heard or and then they're done the
whole season or dis Palpatine's voice I
don't like that's in McDermott they say
the actor's name you know they discover
it like a weird creepy voice but of
course the audience knows so they don't
know we just know that yes yes it's also
not their concern lay there on a
different storyline but that's how they
spoil it for the rest of its kind of
like in shattered Empire I think every
Empire where Leia is visiting isn't
Naboo visiting and she sees in the
palace just like a force projection kind
of vision of daughter and she doesn't
know who Darth Maul it's funny that you
mention that it's a little foreshadowing
of what my theory no we're gonna skip
yours we gotta give marina a rocky oh
and then I mean that 90% of that Rogi is
for respect of keeping that thing on
your head yeah I can carbon dioxide yeah
I can see it leaves your flower and
flowers breathe part about your turning
it back into oxygen for us
photosynthesis thank you okay put it
back on them alright Jovian what are we
foreshadow your rogue theory in the for
issue comic miniseries the road to Force
Unleashed is you you said it was the
shadow to Empire takes place just not
immediately after the fall of the Empire
in Episode six and we know that mantle
takes place five years after the fall of
the Empire so there was a lid
cliffhanger at the end of issue of four
where you find out that the two main
characters that have kind of been with
the heroes of the mo of the rebellion
are actually Poe dameron's parents and
the end of the fourth issue on door was
that and they're on Endor and they're on
Endor ah Luke actually goes with the mom
to save these last two force trees and
for some reason Luke Skywalker decides
to give her one and he's going together
to his little new Jedi Temple so she
plants she says that they're about to
have a baby and he's later I plant this
tree outside of your house and then you
find out her last name is damn her and
then you're like oh that's posed Mama
and Papa and so what they're essentially
telling us is that they're gonna do
plant a forestry outside of their house
where Poe is going to be raised and then
going into Episode seven were like oh
Poe is for sensitive and then they never
touch it at all
yeah they don't never been in episode 8
they never touch it at all so it's just
this this it is canon that poe is for
sensitive but we haven't seen that at
all so what I'm thinking throw out there
real quick he's the best pilot by far
and people constantly reference like how
could he have those skills yeah and I
guess like same thing with Aniki and I
guess that comes back yeah yeah they
were great pilots but there has at least
with Anakin and Luke there was like a
three-part story arc with them and their
forest powers I think though that in the
Mandalorian since it takes place five
years after those incidents I think the
main mission that the bounty hunter will
have is actually having to escort this
force sensitive child from danger from
point A to point B and then we find out
that that son or that that boy is
actually a young okay I like that I'm
wow that's cool that's letting a rookie
towards you yeah but you also get
another half one because you made a
connect to the comics which I'm a fan of
yeah great yeah the reason why we're
coming this year I said kamek because
East Coast no no ER says
there's always colleagues actually
coming to an end soon so I'm a little
sad for that one but I'm excited to see
what they do next yeah but they have all
kinds wending stuff is really great yeah
I also like how marina just as a monster
tree laughed a lot when use kept saying
forestry so you got to stick your
fingers in your mouth holster is that
part of it part of it two options to
breathe Ivan I'm really down with that
Eric told me that he can beat it though
I did guess I did okay you want to take
this one it links obviously this little
guys gonna take you on oh no he didn't
come all the time you have to do the
voice it doesn't have to be that boy
no that's a boy so I'm not gonna take
that from him okay so here's my theory
cut in right here here's my or what I
think the Mandalorians gonna reveal an
episode one just things that we thought
were true at the end of Return of the
Jedi are not actually true so what are
some things that they could change that
people would actually be excited about
well like Patton Oswalt's famous rant in
Parks and Rec said like we pushed it on
the Sarlacc pit the Mandalorians glove
of Boba Fett crawls its way out he
survived I think if you look at this
Mandalorian trailer that just came out
they have like some hits like there's a
Rodian Greedo famously was a roadie and
bounty hunter who worked for who Jabba
the Hutt you see some a Quarren figure
quarry there was also some corn bounty
hunters of Jabba the Hutt what a Jabba
the Hutt survived that explosion on his
like pleasure young and that there are
some pleasure Palpatine know what Murray
about everyone everyone stop marina has
some industries we must talk what is the
marina played with mine my theory is
that after
hun and Luke and their team destroyed
Jabba the Hutt's yacht at in the
beginning of Return of the Jedi there
was like all the bounty hunters and
scavengers on Tatooine went in and took
all of his valuables anything they could
find including any other frozen in
carbonite bodies that he might have had
but Jabba's crime syndicate survived
there are other huts
I think Java might have survived and now
he's trying to track down all the stuff
that was taken from him I believe the
the guy so we talk about comics and then
the bounty hunter series which isn't
canon unfortunately anymore but his dad
Zorba the hunter actually went out for
revenge so would be neat to see that all
play in and have jobs dad show up or one
up job in and I'll say please copy
exactly the events of Ocean's Twelve
where Terry Benedict as I want my money
back with interest huh but it's so Andy
Garcia as Java I'm super into well have
you seen him yeah lately no no he
actually looks great honestly i but so
so it is just like the maybe even the
story of the first season is of
appeasing Jabba yeah yeah I like Ocean's
Twelve the best of the oceans trilogy
right the one where Julie Roberts plays
Tess plane Julie rocks yeah that's
pretty good my [ __ ] you're making fun
of it but I love it
Andy Garcia as Jabba the Hutt he's back
yeah I think Jabba the Hutt's when these
fan favourite characters that like
everyone who loves Star Wars isn't gonna
mind if you revealed that Jabba the Hutt
still alive I don't think that we still
equal as the explosion that killed
Palpatine yet he's the flower was really
upset also though have you seen Jabba
like I mean that's a lot of you know
armor yeah maybe like just the tip of
him gotta like slither away and it has
his whole brain hit his button all his
eyes he grows so two rogue YZ or three
roadies
question two roadies start
it's the perfect negotiating tactic
there yeah an old sith trick yeah I've
seen you inhabit an object before yeah
no keys because object like me having
sex
little tip of a job watch every broke
theory Phillip is like snuck and all
these disgusting little jokes fully
erect yeah they don't realize how
stereotypically nerd joven spike here's
your link us to September 28 referencing
the non-canon guys let's hear let's hear
them again in a tweet starting with
marina poverty sexy Palpatine lives on
in the Death Star hashtag flower monster
that's like Barry White I'm like he can
like basically is in control of the the
the tunes on the ship so he can like of
course so patinas the apprentice to
Barry White
sexy father back and he's on the show
Mandalorian has a young Dameron who's
force sensitive that we find out
actually is attuned to the force and
it's hashtag not another escort mission
weird and hashtag yeah got sexy also I
kind of escort you
yeah yes sick tree it specifically Poe
Dameron right now like Phineas tamarin
or some loser
no this is definitely Poe Dameron we're
gonna have Poe Dameron for sensitive
five-year-old Poe Dameron and move
things with his mind being babysat by an
assassin yes great
yes i kindergarten tweet
Jabba the Hutt
lives once revenge hashtag Pedro Pascal
dressed as Slave Leia he's evolved into
sexy guys he tells in the comments who
you think is actually even the closest I
have a feeling none will see mine is
kinetically connected to the comic books
no but takes look quick to our sponsors
hey everyone erik here and with rick and
morty coming back soon we can announce a
new series called Rick's planed it will
be our official Rick and Morty
after-show a special guest from the Rick
and Morty staff you can access it by
subscribing to our Rick's plain podcast
feed and we're calling it Rick's plain
because if it's one thing where can
Morty fans love its splainin to their
friends with each episodes are really
around if you have ever wondered if mr.
meeseeks is a metaphor for slavery or if
pickle rick is an analogy for painkiller
addictions no you are not overthinking
it you're just broken the way I am
because each episode I'm gonna dive deep
into the black hole of an episode of
Rick and Morty the new season 4 episodes
and leading up to that standout episode
some seasons 1 2 & 3
to decode how each is a secret cry for
help and each episode yeah I'm doing
sitting down with special guests from
the show writers voice actors animators
so that they can confirm whether or not
Myra explanation is legit and give us
some secrets behind these episodes that
we otherwise would never know so
subscribe to Rick explained wherever you
get your podcasts so of all the Rick and
Morty fans you know you could be the
Rick is straight speaking of things that
are getting scary guys marvel to you
they do control a lot of our destiny
phase 4 of the MCU is going to expand
what Marvel movies can be breaking out
of the superhero genre we've said that
this is our personal time they're gonna
go to different directors they're gonna
expand into new kinds of films we're
getting the spy movie in Black Widow
right we're getting the martial arts
movie in shang-chi and we're getting
what they've described as a horror movie
come on Philip you gotta separate those
souls a horror movie in Doctor Strange
and multiverse of madness so assuming
that they still want to do more horror
even beyond that movie because there's
it's one of the primary genres it's one
of the biggest money-making genres and
period how can Marvel make movies that
are good horror films but still feel
like a Marvel movie still got the Feige
touch so pitch me what your Marvel movie
that's a Marvel movie and simultaneously
a horror movie is gonna be okay so I
think spider-man far from home gave us
like a great quiet tree I think we've
shown that if you can play with people's
perception of reality like that's a real
great way to like terrify someone like
the way Mysterio trapped Peter in that
illusion what happens such a great great
sequence and like that just shows us the
untapped potential of things like the
reality stone and just swapping around
through like the realities that Doctor
Strange does hopefully Doctor Strange
the multiverse of madness which I have
said sounds like a Rob Zombie lyric will
explore it because like Scott Derrickson
is the director that he loves these kind
of horror film director yeah start in
horror films as did James Gunn would
like slither yeah you know so like they
have all these guys who love making
horror films so I would love to see like
a movie that beyond multiverse of
madness just like shows a character
trapped in like a reality swap of
situation like Scarlet Witch want to
maximov and hopefully wanda vision will
explore some of this showing her like
swapping around through reality she
doesn't know what's real and what isn't
and it terrifies her psychological
thriller kind of yeah I was actually
thinking of get out when you were saying
that where it's like like being in an
environment that's like on its surface
they're like uh specifically the Wanda
vision idea up if it is gonna be that
50s you know Norman walk what rock
Hualien kind of life that's kind of what
get out is depicting right everyone's
like so cheery and a Stepford Wives yeah
what I hope Wanda vision is is it starts
that way it starts the like the vision
comic book where it's like showing his
own atomic family but it descends into
something closer to the shining where
like it's a character who's like trapped
in there and that - yeah I want to see
this so bad yeah so I hope that's what I
don't know if that's the direction
they're going but I I think in order to
set up Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness and needs to
laughs that sitcom that classic sitcom
formula they seem to be tapping into
into something that's really messed up
so that dr. strange can fix it in his
film so this is one of those films yeah
it is one division is her story as
reality collapses around her in the way
that like she looks around him there's
like blood pouring out of the bathroom
door there's like a guy in a bear
costume doing something horrible yeah
yeah and she doesn't know what real is
anymore just like the Avengers
disassembled left to wander vision in
the comics so we needed to have the
House of X our House of M sorry
storyline to where they tried to fix it
into something new and permanent yeah so
rather than the next horror film being
like a movie beyond multiverse of
madness I'm suggesting that Wanda vision
will be a weekly horror series that's so
cool that's cool
she's like just evolving over time
that's a really cool video game that's
like that that starts like we're like
taking care of kids or something and
it's very sweet but then like oh there's
little things like like you can't happy
whew
it's the one where you can't help but
like grab a knife you like it's like the
only character the thing actually has
like has to hold a knife and then once
it holds a knife and they can never put
it down and the only other action has us
to stab now yeah all right jebin what
where's marvel going with this with a
horror film the MCU and how do they pull
it off how is it Feige and marvel III
think Marvel her and horse I think
Marvel's done a really great job of
taking obscure characters some new or
some older and giving them these these
movies that just become amazing parts of
our history I think they're gonna do it
again after Doctor Strange I think we
are gonna see some of the scarier
characters and there was a character
created in 2001 that I'm surprised we
haven't seen more of yet maybe you guys
might know the name Elsa you know frozen
Sid no Elsa bloodstone absolutely okay a
Monster Hunter kind of Allah Buffy the
Vampire Slayer but more guns and
ass-kicker II I think it something that
we want to see in cinema more as more
women being badasses that can take their
own movies or their own franchises and
go in that direction you got the tree
support this is also a character that
has crossed over and with Ghost Rider
who
did have for a brief moment his own Hulu
series that supposed to happen
got canceled so I think that we'll see a
Ghost Rider movie or at least spin-off
with Elsa bloodstone which would mean by
the way that they're saying that you're
thinking of newly cast Ghost Rider they
get rid of the the ABC version I think
well it's also a different character
there's two different characters I would
love to see the ABC character kind of
come over because I want to see more
cross between TV and and the MCU verse
but in this bloodstone you get a movie
you can also go into monsters you can
get scary with it and I think the most
important part of it though is it
doesn't have to be rated R people think
that you viewer and have a good scary
movie it has to be rated R that is not
at all true some of my favorite horror
movies ever have not been rated R Sixth
Sense the insidious movies dead silence
was a go movie g13 which won lego lego
movie scene yeah and also I cut with my
heartache I don't think Marvel has to go
rated R with her like it like a Deadpool
I don't think it has to be rated R
there's a way to do great action and
still pull it off in a pg-13 way so I
think the same thing can be done with
action and horror at the same time you
can have a strong pg-13 movie but also
Marvel does like to break records and
right now we have a new r-rated movie
with a giant box-office hit with with
Joker and just Marvel's over there like
we can beat that so they might want to
do an r-rated movie just to like beat
another record what what does your movie
feel like I think it it should be very
slow and creepy have that James Bond
style where you can't really see what's
around the corner even though the person
can have that claustrophobic feel of
monsters being around you while you're
trying to hunt them at the same time so
it's like these demons that are always
present over your shoulder but you can't
always see them and I think that's a way
to get into a viewers head where there's
something there and you know it
like you've turned the lights off in
your house and you're going to bed and
you know there's something behind you
but you can't see it and that is one of
the scariest feelings that we as human
beings could know and I think to play on
that with actual monsters is a very fun
direction that can get scary and just
messed up on multiple levels yeah maybe
that's where me tomorrow will free you
is that it has the that terrifying
lights out kind of thing going on the
short film lights out if remember that
going on but then it actually has like
named characters who have their own
backstories and height flushed out
monsters yeah because like there are so
many great monsters that have made their
appearances in the in the Marvel Comics
like Dracula is an actual Marvel
character like I'm not saying he would
be in this particular movie but there's
lots of demons and monsters that you can
touch on from history and lore that show
up in Marvel Comics that also could be
fighting alongside these you know the
one that can actually go outside and
touch things that monster old and then
you can also tie in like the the horror
characters into like your MCU major
movies like The Avengers movies that
happen later on where it's it was just
nice to see them especially in a darker
sense then interact with characters and
maybe a more lighter sense you get to
see that juxtaposition of their
characters which will be great to see on
camera I want to ask you another
follow-up question because I noticed a
marina started sweating building down
yeah
but ur teeth are falling out so yeah we
all have a lot of time Marina what's
your marble meets horror pitch globe
yeah Thank You marina
that's so recap dudes for me your horror
film or TV series I guess in the MCU how
it's marble and natori give it to me a
tweet Wanda vision collapses into the
shining as reality becomes distorted cut
pause yeah I'm Rogi Elsa bloodstone the
female that you didn't know is kicking
so much ass is now fighting the monsters
you didn't know we're standing right
behind you hashtag Buffy who just you
just got lost a rogue
look it's in my hand and I was cuz I
know I was like you know what your idea
is okay but you reference Buffy in a
nice way and I was gonna slide it over
and I was gonna be so happy and instead
you get a little half one because Buffy
Summers is who there's the one of those
Phillips I'm now holding you can't take
it away from me
the Buffy TV show overrated and does not
stand the test of time hasn't been here
before he doesn't know I can't take
these away
[Applause]
joven is down to half cookie and marina
give it to us really yeah
Marvel goes work with blade hashtag some
hookers are always trying to ice skate
uphill I love that line first of all I
think it's in reference to joven just
take all of her roadies and she can't
see out of her prefer here I'll give you
an extra one
and since droven stole one of yours I'll
give you another one and I'll give Eric
another and Jovi joven don't worry
because you still have a chance to win
this okay great that's the worst part
that's worse guys all right
so row questions here questions that I
haven't seen you guys I'm seen you ready
yes yeah all right Nephilim are you
ready marina Netflix is testing out a
new feature that lets you change
playback speed you guess is what Netflix
content should be watched in double
speed yes house of cards so you don't
have time to think about how horrible of
a person is lead is you don't like Robin
recovering right
ah the Great British Bake Off is on
Netflix right I want to watch that in
half speed because obvious reasons yes
nothing format of the question Java all
the nature shows so you like life and
planet Earth and all that so you just
get to the part to the at the end where
they're like humans are ruining the
planet and then you're like oh now I
know what I have to do with your
estimable you want to get to that part
faster with a screen I'm only gonna give
joven or Oggy for that one because he
broke the rules
and I want to keep them nice and
confused next question what MCU
character would make the best vampire
that's not blade can I say blade yeah no
um Keanu Reeves in whatever play
character he plays cos he never ages
oh yeah sorry oh okay I'm gonna go with
Peggy Hill because she obviously was
sucking the life force out of Captain
America because he was only gone for
like another 70 years and he went
pecking Carter hill from King Carter way
too old
Captain America should be aging with the
serum he went from like zero to like the
sweet moment where she hooks cap up on a
me just a little bit each week alright
I'm into it and marina my idea who
should be vampire is Coulson because he
keeps coming back and now he can just
live forever agent Phil Coulson it was
not create technology he's just a
vampire just a vampire cool you know
it's it's surprising Joventut the only
rogue youth around I guess he's come
back and then finally this is the last
road question whoever comes out on top
of this from Rhonda right you guys
filled out your wish requests early I
will make one your wishes come true the
rest of you will never have a wish come
true again guys what is the worst
Halloween candy go circus peanuts
plant canopy dancers go peeps peeps the
worse they are from Easter whoppers like
you bite into those and just like send
shivers down and they're always in like
those big bags of candy what has like a
bunch of other good candy so you just
wind up with whoppers at the end it's
like it is a dice roll every time it
could be a stale whopper yeah you should
bite into it just like I'm getting goose
bumps it's like way better because
you're like how the [ __ ] did this Easter
candy kit in my Halloween next year I'm
buying bulk around Eastern giving them
out from Halloween you're right I I my
Easter candy would be a really bad one
and then so does droven because I'm
pretty against hurting my teeth when I'm
trying to have fun yeah let's do a quick
roki total update what we got aya for
Eric as for Rogan these quarters are
halves quarters oh I have a half I have
four and a half I have three three and
that leaves joven is our winner and his
last episode on counted mine by touch
only Eric's wish not gonna happen
marinas wish oh nope never just can I
please take off the basket just like say
like how many comments do you think
we're gonna have like how do they not
know she's a demagogue and I still don't
know what that is Joshua Obon Shia would
like everyone to defend Star Wars
Episode eight as a good Star Wars movie
and here's what I'll do because we're a
little over time I'll say on our social
media platforms we have to send out a
tweet that the defend Star Wars Episode
eight go to each of our to remind you
guys that Eric we're coming find you
you can find me here on new rock stars
on Twitter and Instagram at a Vox coming
up on the channel this week we have some
cool stuff a preview of our shining
breakdown we can make like re-watch it
and the full thing is exclusive to
patrons but you're gonna want to see
this whole day it's like 35
it's long it's like my favorite break is
oh and most intense breakdown you've
done absolutely yeah so you'll see like
a little taste of it for everyone on the
channel just to give you a sense of what
you're gonna want to see yeah and we're
not taking away from you by the way if
you're not a patron it's a the patron
specifically paid for this to be made
yeah I'm smarter on the internet because
of your breakdown you can find me at the
joven Shire Twitter and Instagram and
YouTube we're have a bunch of different
content there and I saw the cartoon
recently so that should actually be
popping up in that awesome I hope it's
the Jetsons if I do I want twitter
twitter at marina masters and here with
Eric sometimes great just wanna come
back guys I'm filling if I'm an
instagram and twitter at philip molina
make sure to follow new rock stars at
new rock stars also make sure to get
this podcast feed because it comes out
first there and then you could have
heard all this disastrous nonsense
before you got to see it and then just
the way we all cuz we're all curious I
just we're gonna say goodbye as marina
slowly takes this mask off her head and
I want to see what her skin and like
Twilight Zone it's just her face now
yeah guys never tell her fine
agree and editors just have her face
blurred be tired with like colors that
are changing
[Music]